[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
Rett this week at the round table of
demm lighting we are doing what has
become somewhat of a tradition and we
are going through our top
purchases of the Year see what we can
learn about each other from the things
that we have chosen to enhance our lives
with okay um and I look back there's a
number of things that I've mentioned
throughout the year I was I I tried to
bring some new things to the oh youe
everybody listens to every single
episode like you know it for those that
do I love you and second of all uh I
don't want to bore you with the same
story what if you make it even more
interesting what if you lie about it is
it supposed to be top purchases or it's
just to me it's just
purchases um I mean I I included things
that I thought did you rank yours no I
didn't rank them I included things that
I thought
uh might be fun to talk about okay yeah
I kind of did that and the next episode
is definitely my favorite recurring
episode where we talk about our top
moments of the year so be ready for that
I have to break with the theme of this
episode and not talk about a purchase at
all first because there's something that
happened to me well maybe you could say
it's something that I did okay maybe you
could say it's something that I did to
myself
over my Thanksgiving break that I have
not told you about and you mean to tell
me by the fact that there's no twinkle
in your eye right now you pull a muscle
that you have not heard through my wife
to your wife that something
happened you know cuz trust me you would
know I hear so many things about things
that I know you do things that go wrong
in your life that makes its way to me
via your wife to my wife it could just
all blend together when you start
talking about oh yeah I heard about I
think this one you running over the baby
giraffe no dude this one stands out okay
then maybe I haven't heard about it I
think this might be the dumbest thing
you've ever done no but it might be one
of the most embarrassing things that I'm
deciding to share on the internet okay
I'm not really that embarrassed by it
but I don't know maybe I'll get
embarrass you should be I don't even
know what it is but you should be well
um I just was like it's just one of
those things where I just started
thinking well I at least I can talk
about it on the podcast it'll get you
know that will redeem this and it made
me feel better knowing that I was going
to share it with you I'll be the judge
of
that so um for Thanksgiving we just
spent a couple of days back in North
Carolina me Christy and Lando flew back
of course the older kids off at College
they weren't able to
um leave when we left cuz you didn't
even really it wasn't even really
Thanksgiving it was the weekend before
and then we wanted to be back by proper
Thanksgiving so that lilan Lincoln could
come back into town and we could have a
Thanksgiving at the house it now that
the majority of our kids are out of the
house it definitely feels different and
it definitely feels
different I mean than just having one
out of the house when they come back
home for Thanksgiving I'm actually
starting to
experience something that didn't happen
with just Lily and I don't even remember
how Thanksgiving worked the previous
year I think we all came to North
Carolina but anyway you burnt the ham
that's like no that was that was that
was two years ago last year well last
year you didn't the first year you wared
warmed I got the Honey Baked Ham I got
that again this year it's it's pricey
but it's worth it um so yeah it it
definitely feels different to come like
have the kids come back home and you're
experiencing Thanksgiving in that way so
we had a good time but when I was in
North Carolina because we didn't have
the older kids with
us um we were able to stay at my mom's
house again which is something that we
used to do okay but in the last few
years the kids are getting older they're
getting bigger bigger beds bigger bigger
rooms need for more space we kind of
stay at an Airbnb and then we visit my
mom a lot they can't get in the race car
beds anymore right all the other well
the blowup mattresses all three lined up
in the living room floor just it it it's
a lot but um we were excited to do that
again with now that it was just Lando so
it was like a blast from the past so
we're staying three nights at Mom's
house and the back so Lando sleeps in
the living room on the blowup mattress
and Christie and I sleep back on the
double bed in the uh in the back of the
hall there across the hallway from Mom's
bedroom and um so we're trying to get
used to sleeping in double bed again
even though that's what we did for the
majority of our
marriage and you're starting you're
trying to guess what happened yeah and I
hope what I just thought of didn't
happen so I'll just I'll just log it
don't yeah log it and tell me later when
it's not it what you think it is I
certainly hope it is what happened
though
um I what's the best way to say this um
I think I just need to come out and say
it I wet the
bed okay that okay that wasn't what I
was thinking I I peed
myself in the bed okay like and I'm not
talking about a trickle you went for it
I'm talking
full well this is what happened I can't
laugh at you too much because I was a
bed wetter I was I was not a bed wet as
a kid um let me tell you what happened
okay okay I just remember um you know
there's with the time change and
everything that was it I I
remember I remember that I was asleep
and then all of a sudden it was the it
was starting to be light outside because
Christy woke me up getting out of bed
presumably to go pee and at that point I
remember thinking to myself man I really
have to pee as well oh so you you
remember you were awake at one point I
was awake enough to think that I really
need to peed as well but I also just
really want to sleep some more so I went
back to sleep Leal combination by the
time christe got back in the bed I don't
she didn't wake me up when she got back
in the bed I don't remember any of that
um and time passed it wasn't like a
meting or anything time passed cuz
Christy was totally asleep and it takes
her a while to get back to
sleep next thing I
know I'm it's just it's it's warm and
wet down there I'm laying on my back and
did you catch yourself and uh yeah it
was like warm and wet all over my crotch
which is the source of yeah that's
usually how it works p
and I wake up just a little bit and I
like my hand was on my hand was here on
my like Belt Line and my hand was wet
and I like I threw the covers off of one
hand and I think I I think I I pinched
the hose with the other I think I grabed
the hose cuz it was still going it was
still going right that's usually how it
happens it was still going and I I like
throw the covers off and I like run to
the bathroom and I'm talking about a lot
of pee like running down my legs pee
both legs like like I I might need to
drag a mop down the hallway level of pee
and I get I go in the bathroom and then
I like I sit I I sat down on the toilet
because I was just too discombobulated
to stand and uh there was there was a
lot more of of the package to be
delivered mhm so yeah I did I did cut
off the flow but not before I
completely wet myself well and the
sheets yeah the bed too like how much
got got on the bed um there was this it
it spilled over my hip into a puddle
yeah you knew that this wasn't something
you could get away with without talking
to someone about right well and then I'm
like I'm so freaking soaked I just
immediately get in the shower and then
christe was like yeah I heard the I like
woke up it was early and like you I
heard the
shower but when I came back in the room
she was still asleep I was like well I'm
not hold on so you wet it when she was
next to you yeah Oh I thought okay she
went to the bathroom and then then that
got you thinking about PE she got she
got back in theed went back to sleep I
went back to sleep did it leak to her
side did she come in contact with no it
was on the my left side she long enough
yeah
and
uh I was I was what if that's how it
work I was quite embarrassed uh at the
time yeah I understand that and then I'm
like sleeping on the couch for a little
bit but I was like I was like yeah
chrisy I I wet the bed and she was
like you peed the bed or something else
and I was like oh man no it was
definitely p i could I definitely know
the difference I mean with a puddle that
big Welly that's
a I mean that I would have a different
uh career trajectory I
think if uh if it wasn't p and the
puddle was that big is all I'm saying
money shot um did you you were obviously
you were a little embarrassed we'll talk
about that yeah but were you
also I was embarrassed to tell my mommy
mommy were you concerned about like is
something wrong with me because i' I've
wet the bed once we can talk about I
don't remember the details but I I wet
the bed once as an
adult you have yeah I have never wet the
bed as an adult it was never a challenge
for me as a kid so there was no like
throwback or anything but let me tell
you the next three
mornings I was really nervous like I the
moment I woke up I was like oh do I need
to pee I do need to pee I better get up
and Chris even even the second morning
like when I started to stir a little bit
Christy Christy rolls over wide awake
she's
like do you need to pee yeah right you
might need to go to the bathroom did you
already pee yourself we were a
little nervous about it yeah I was like
you're probably not not going to happen
again is this some sort of a prostate
thing I don't know I'm 45 does it mean
something does it mean emotionally oh no
I thought physically yeah like me
getting old but but emotionally yeah it
uh but they say as a bed wetter I should
know this
like um I went to
bed I don't know I don't know how old I
was but like Beyond when you were
supposed to like to be classified as a
bed wetter like I remember wetting the
bed right now still as a kid though yeah
I mean I wasn't like in my teenage years
it was like you know like six seven
years old eight years old maybe you wet
the bed occasionally and it was like
embarrassing and they say that it means
something you know what I'm say saying
not physically like there's something
psychological and emotional I'm not
going down that path no right so I
overcame it and then what I have
experienced as a and I think this is you
tell me if this is a common
experience sometimes you have to pee so
bad while you're sleeping that you dream
about peeing does that happen to you I
don't remember if I was having a dream
but I have to has that ever happened to
you it has not happened to me but I have
to think that's what was happening and I
just don't remember the dream that like
I was for for it for me to completely
release my bladder on myself I had to be
dreaming that I was peeing because it
was the last thing I thought as I was
falling back asleep was I I do need to
pee right well and I was like I'm not
going to think about it Beyond this I'm
not going to make this into a thing you
didn't besides the story didn't go on
Reddit I did not you go on Reddit for
everything go on Reddit and be like
adult bed wedding one time just I here's
what I thought there might be a whole
sub subred if it happens twice more
maybe once more but I said to myself if
this happens twice
more then I'll start searching about it
but I am not it probably won't though I
am not going down that path after
wetting one little bed it was a new bed
you know I feel like it was a new bed I
did it in my own bed how old were you
were you married oh this is in the past
10 years oh really
okay so let me go back so I would do it
as a kid super embarrassing like it was
like you know I think we at one point we
got like a tell your like a mattress
cover or something you know like it was
like it happened occasionally it
happened often enough that we had to
like take precautions this it's
embarrassing you don't want to be known
as a bed wetter yeah and then of course
I overcome it and I don't think about it
ever again but throughout my life I've
had had what I thought was a common
experience which is like if you have to
pee and you're still in bed and you're
dreaming a lot of times you'll have
dreams about having to pee like you'll
have to pee in your dream makes sense
and what I have found is
that it is not uncommon if I'm having a
dream where I have to urinate that I
will urinate in my
dream and then wake up and realize that
I haven't urinated I just really needed
to and so CU sometimes you're like
literally in a dream you'll find a
urinal or I will I don't know about you
and you'll empty it and you'll be like
man I'm there for a while and
then you go on on your dream and then
you're like I still got a urinate
because you haven't actually your
bladder is feeling the pressure dream
going to multiple urinals yeah sometimes
three four
maybe that's strange dude um that is
strange and I don't well I don't think
it is strange what I'm saying is that I
I venture to Guess that this this is a
common experience of people having to
pee this is what you need to call in
about 1888 ear one it's the number one
however we want you to tell I need to
know if you peed yourself in a bed as an
adult I need to know that R made me feel
better but I need you to make me feel
better by telling me you do it or that
you've done it uh you're probably jie
you care to weigh in on this uncom I I
have
stories but it could be for another day
another day no if if we get enough if we
get enough uh voicemails we can talk
about it and make it a whole
episode yeah there we go well there we
go okay well that feels good this
episode is not about urination stories
we got other things to talk about we've
been through things yeah I've been
through things I I have not but I have
had the dreams of having and then waking
up being like Oh I need to pee but like
in my dream I'm like gotten trying to
find a bath bathroom okay good I didn't
I'm not crazy if you're peeing in your
dream but not peeing in reality that's a
that's that is a I mean that's like
that's a dichotomy that's a powerful
dichotomy the scary thing is is the
time because every time that happens and
then I wake up and the thing that was
the impetus to wake me up was the fact
that I have to pee so bad and I was
peeing in my dream I have these
flashbacks to being a little kid who
peed in his bed and I'm like oh did
I do it did I pee in my bed and it never
happens except one time when I started
peeing in my dream and then I woke up
with the sensation of warmth warmth
spreading spreading and I immediately
caught myself and stopped but and I did
you pinch the hose uh it didn't it I
didn't have enough that it leaked over
my shorts and down into the bed it
didn't wet the mattress it wet my
underwear and I was like what the hell
like and then I was like hold on maybe
this was a a weird wet dream like I I
was trying to find any other explanation
other than oh I've wet the bed
again yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh I think
I I went I I like took my uh you know
underwear off and and peed and then went
back to bed and kind of forgot about it
until you just brought this story up CU
you never told me um I mean the moment
I've the first opportunity I've had to
do it for public consumption I told you
about it but I was worried that it might
mean that something had happened to me
like psychologically oh not I wasn't
thinking it was a it was a physical
problem but it hasn't happened again and
it's been years but you are afraid of it
so you're
Pro now I'm afraid of nobody wants to PE
the bed I'm afraid of it now yeah you
should be and as we get older we're
goingon to be you know they say you you
get up and pee in the middle of the
night yeah and I haven't I'm 46 and that
and and somebody who hydrates a lot I'm
surprised that you don't have to do that
I don't have to do that yet I did
however
just last night 3:00 a.m. you hear when
Shawn hits the floor yeah is when he's
ready and and he got his timing off or
something so I had to take him out to
pee and poop in the middle of the night
and while I was up I peed and I was like
well this is a lot of pee I was like I
guess I was going to make it until six
o'clock with all this pee and I would
have any other night you thought about
it though you got a little scared what
is the thing that you thought I was
going to say before we move on your
purchases I thought that you got the bed
with your mom thinking it was your
wife like cuz you oh man the way you the
way you set it up was like I want you to
call me and tell me if you have gotten
into bed with your mom and that's why I
started laugh thinking it was your wife
because it was like if if you have done
that you need to call us too middle of
the night d double bed like it's your
it's not your home hang a right inste
left hang left or right yeah that's what
I thought you were going to say and you
got in and didn't realize until the
morning the morning when you were
peeing when you woke your mom up peeing
on
Mommy now what did your mom think about
what did Sue say about this when you
said did you tell you Pete yourself I
did okay I did uh she was very
non-judgmental she was she's she's the
perfect Mom that she always is she was
like well do you want sausage and eggs
or do you do what can make it better do
you want grits do you want grits you
want to stuff some grits in there next
time do you want some grits I think that
was literally her response do you want
some grits okay so she wasn't worried
Christy wasn't worried but Lando wanted
I mean when we C we come back home I
told Lando he's telling I mean like uh
Lincoln comes home walks in the
door dad tell Lincoln what you did kind
of a thing then Lily comes
in hey Lily ask Dad what he did did
that's D what he did I was like this is
this is my story to tell on my terms
well I think it's also your kid's
story no it's not yeah yeah yeah when
your dad pees himself you get to tell
that story like you write that in your
Memoir trust me all the embarrassing
stuff that you've done well all the
stories that I've told at Le T Gally
include them they do definitely have the
right to tell any story they want about
me and I'm okay well I wouldn't worry
too much I've done it once you've done
it once as an adult yeah but
Jenna's I think done it a lot so I think
I think we're waiting we're waiting on
your calls to bring Jenna out of uh I
hiding now Jenna not did not make any
assumptions but I don't know if being in
an altered state is it qualifies as a as
a real experience oh okay
okay we're just talking about two
completely sober men pissing themselves
in bed then I have never done that yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's different it's a
different thing you know I have illness
stories that are worse but that's also
altered state um let's let's get to
talking about top purchases of 2023 but
you know what we would like to maybe
inform some of your potential top
purchases that can still be made in 23
you like that transition talking about
mythical.com check out this color
blocked shirt that we are selling at
mythical.com good gracious and there's
there's joggers it's it says less talk
about that it's embroidered it's very
soft it's very Supple it's very green
it's very color blocked it's got pockets
you can and now if you wet these got a
back pocket if you wet these it'll show
right through it'll show more on one
side than the
other you know it'll show more on this
side but if you pee in a block pattern
then it it'll it'll seem you can turn
this side that color by pissing on
it or having your mom piss on it if
you're accidentally sleeping with her
right mythical.com get those
joggers ear biscuits is brought to you
by better help you know what it is that
time of year a giftgiving time of year
and you're thinking about hopefully
giving gifts to the people in your life
right you're giving to others you're
giving to your family we're going to one
of those dirty Santa parties where we're
going to be giving gifts to everybody
else well whether or not your family
gives gifts this holiday season you get
to Define how you give to yourself oo so
whether it's by starting therapy going
easier on yourself during the tough
moments or treating yourself to a day of
complete rest remember to give yourself
some love this holiday season we're huge
advocates for therapy and we want it to
be accessible to everyone so if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely on online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule all you got to
do is fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapist at any time
for no additional charge in the season
of giving give yourself what you need
with better help visit betterhelp.com
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com ear biscuits is supported by
Thrive Market whenever I go to the
grocery store and I'm like trying to get
something and then I'm looking at the
different prices for the different types
of the same
thing I I get overwhelmed man and I
still don't know if I'm getting the best
price or the best thing that's where
Thrive Market it sounds like you need
Thrive Market link I I it really does
doesn't it well Thrive Market is one of
my go-tos for when I need organic
grocery and household essentials and the
convenience of getting it all quickly
shipped to my doorstep is a huge
timesaver I save money every time I
order I think I saved like $50 last time
I used it the chomp beef sticks we have
in the office are so much cheaper
through Thrive than at the store on top
of the massive savings on each order
Thrive Market has a deals page that
changes daily and gives cash back on so
many Brands and they have a price match
guarantee not only does thrive markets
Thrive I like how you said thrive thrive
Market save me money but they also save
me time I love the filters on their
website or app they have over
whether you're looking for certified
gluten-free snacks or non-toxic cleaning
Essentials you can curate your own
shopping experience with the click of a
button one of my favorite Parts is that
when you join Thrive Market you're also
helping a family in need with their one
forone membership matching program you
join they give join in on the savings
with Thrive market today and get 30% off
your first order plus a free $60 gift go
to thrivemarket.com for 30% off your
first order plus a free $60 gift that's
th Ive
market.com thrivemarket.com
all right you didn't rank your purchases
I didn't rank them but I mean they're
they're in you
know they're in an order that I thought
might help with interest okay starting
with low interest yeah I
mean too low I
purchased a chain
scrubber chain mail as in like what a
night in medieval times would wear as
underwear
y or whatever protection yeah so if you
have chain mail so I've really been
cooking a lot with the cast iron skillet
right and almost exclusively if I'm
going to cook something on the stove I'm
using the cast iron skillet I've got a
big one and I've got a smaller one and
you're dressed as a knight and as you
know you're not supposed to wash I mean
it's a it's actually a little bit it's
not technically true but you don't wash
a cast iron skillet in the same way that
you wash a non-stick pan or a stainless
steel pan right you season it so it's
got this season on seasoning on it which
is a misnomer a bit because it really is
just like a layer of polymers from there
being fat in the pan and then it getting
to a certain temperature and it
basically creates a non-stick surf
but then you have to really it does
impact the taste in a positive way right
I believe that's a little bit overrated
but yes it is because what actually what
you're trying to do is I always thought
that it was like oh you want the taste
of everything that you've cooked in this
pan to be in there like seasoning and
maybe that's where the word comes from I
don't know I'm I don't know Josh could
probably tell me this but really what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
create a non-stick surface not a surface
that makes everything taste a certain
way okay it's a non-stick surface so but
you do want to clean it in fact you want
to get the other food out of there and
so most of the time if you've got a
really good non-stick surface what like
what I do is I finish cooking and then I
immediately just put it under water and
most of the time everything that was in
that pan just go because I've got a well
seasoned pan it kind of just washes
right off and then I put some oil on it
heat it up and you know it's just and
kind of keep keep it going but if you
get something in your pan that doesn't
come out out when you just spray water
on it there's this chain mail that is
wrapped around rubber in a circle that
you just keep right there in a little
holster inside your sink and you just
rub it you just rub it so it doesn't
clean chain mail it's chainmail that
cleans it's chain mail that cleans that
gets all the little bits off without
compromising your nonstick layer it's
been a GameChanger for me cuz what I was
doing is I was putting coarse salt in
into a lot of people do this yeah yeah I
do it cor salt in there and moving it
around and stuff and I still do that the
salt absorbs the Blackness and then you
break it into it's an abrasive you know
that but I think that this works better
personally it's easier you don't have to
do the salt and then get it out just and
because the chain mail is it's like
Loops it doesn't scratch doesn't scratch
huh chain mail scrubber how much how
much do you pay for that roughly
unfortunately I did not put the down and
it's no longer a clickable but I mean
we're talking less than 10 bucks I mean
this is this is not an expensive item
okay get one if You' got cast iron
um first purchase item I want to talk
about is
the
PTI just it's the word cute with the
letters P and E in front of it
PTI dog
basket for
bike okay and uh I throw this in the
Amazon on cart and um we have a family
thread it's called fam you again now
that majority of our kids are out of the
house we've we've started this family
thread and we've gotten decent at
putting stuff in there you know just
kind of you know and then you can
evaluate if everybody doesn't respond in
some way then it's like all right then
you start to keep a record and it's like
well do I need to give so and so a call
what's going on here yeah yeah yeah you
know the family thread is like a nice
innocuous way to like just keep keep in
touch you were like one of the first
Generations if not the first generation
to have a family text thread for your
immediate family and isn't that CU we
didn't our the kids our parents didn't
have that well the fact that we call it
a text thread I've been told by my kids
severely dates us it is a group chat but
I cannot not call it a text thread group
chat group chat is is what it's actually
called like they gave me so much
about that and I cannot stop saying it
but text thread it's a text thread to us
but it's a group chat it's a group chat
anyway uh in the group chat I don't know
if it was I think it was Lincoln first
because he'll go he'll he'll order some
stuff using his mama's Amazon account
you know what I'm saying yeah and now
every time I order stuff I have
to I really have to note that shipping
address y oh this I'm about to ship my
peti dog basket for bike to Lincoln's
dorm room yeah I don't want that I don't
want that cuz the dog ain't there but he
goes in there and so he put in the text
that he was
like I think it was him it could have
been Lily dad what are you doing and I
was like what he was
like there's a dog basket for a bike in
the Amazon cart he's like he's like
keeping tabs on me through the Amazon
card and then like Lily was like what
hold on is there what's going on here
they started to become concerned for
whatever dog or dogs I was going to be
presumably biking around you don't have
a great track record yeah it was a year
in fact in fact it was a year ago that I
broke my collar bone on my mountain bike
and all I have is a mountain bike I
don't I don't hurt your wrist but that
wasn't on the bike that was the one
wheel yeah but I I you know I don't have
a beach cruiser they know that the only
bike that I have is a full suspension
mountain
bike and then I'm like yeah I'm about to
add a dog
helmet to the Amazon car don't worry
hold on is that a real thing no I was
joking
oh and um yes so this thing shows up and
it is a could be though it you mount it
on the front of the
handlebars so it's like he's and then
you put a dog in it and you can like I'm
familiar with a a bike basket yeah you
you've seen uh I've seen Mary Poppins or
what sound of
music I think you're talking about
wizard of O I don't know I've seen a
woman with a bike basket in a classic
film I think and I've also just like
been to Venice Beach that's where you
could come to my house yeah
yeah so yeah I put this I I got a bike
basket
because
Jasper every morning
he's like he he's so eager when he hops
out of bed or the moment I stir he's
like oh oh my God oh my God it's time to
walk oh it's another day when I get to
take a walk oh I'm going to walk right
now oh my God he just moved that means
he's going to it's time for a
walk that's how he
is so every morning it's for a year now
it I've gotten in the habit of taking I
used to just take him for a walk and I
was like Jade you need to start taking a
walk and
Jade's she's gotten bigger she's gotten
buff as a result of me walking her every
morning okay I question this but I
haven't seen her so I don't know when
the kids came home for Thanksgiving they
were like what why is Jade she's like
her chest has gotten more Dev her chest
is more buff she's doing something else
she's doing work she's working out on
the side I don't know and I was like do
you think something's wrong with her I
think talking trims trims you does it
buk you I don't think it bulks you up
she's getting maybe it's just in her
older age did you change your diet in
her no did not change her diet in her
older age I think she's kind of getting
fluffier in her like tors her upper
torso but I also like to think that
she's in better shape because I've been
walking early well she probably is but
you know who's not in better shape me
you because Jasper guilts me into
walking him every single morning and I
used to go there there were stretches
before I broke my collar bone that I
would go
biking e at least every other morning
maybe every morning so I was like I I
what am I going to
do I I got to start I got to get back on
my bike I got to I got to do some form
of workout Beyond just walking these
dogs well how fast do you walk every
morning I don't even walk that fast I
mean well if you just pick up the pace a
little bit he probably would like it and
then you basically get a good workout in
well but Jay Jay can't keep up ankle
weights ankle weights yeah and and arm
weights okay speed walk it that's not
that well this that was not my idea I'm
just trying to solve problems here my
idea was well if I want to go biking and
I don't want to feel guilty for leaving
Jasper at home because he will make me
feel guilty the moment I come back from
biking he'll he's just sitting there
just
like we didn't walk we didn't walk
you you left you must have walked
without me yeah well why couldn't I have
walked with you I can smell it on you
why couldn't I I can smell the walk on
you it's like you walked without me you
know and it's and I feel horrible yeah
you should so I'm like I'm going to have
my cake and eat it too I'm going to ride
my bike and I'm gonna and my dog's going
to go with me but is that good enough
for him is that what he wants or does he
want to actually walk he's got the fomo
I thought maybe that would do it so I
put him I I got the thing and like I
strapped it on there and you know I I
put him in it and I'm walking I'm
driving around the cuac and he's like
you you leash him in so they can't jump
out because he seemed like he might want
to jump out but he wasn't scared so then
I got up the next
morning I drove to the place where I
mountain bike more of a flatter place
but still with some single track okay
and once I got to a place where I didn't
think there was anybody else my plan was
to let them out of the basket so like
he's in the basket and we're riding like
darthy and Toto and then we get to the
the single track and I take him out of
the basket I just put him down beside me
and I just start riding my mountain bike
and then now I'm that cool guy who
mountain bikes with this dog chasing him
hey isn't this great not really how did
that go um because I started meeting
people who were jogging on this path and
uh or riding bikes on the path and I
would get out of the way on my bike and
then I would look behind me and Jasper
would just like he would not move yeah
right he he he didn't knew no Trail
etiquette yeah I'm like apologizing for
my dog and like then all these other
bikers are like
oh you know and then it's like somebody
had another dog on a leash and I got a
dog and he's not on a leash and like I'm
irresponsible so then when I got through
that part I'm like ah you got to stay in
the basket you're still having fun
having a bonding time
and I wrote him
around we got back home I didn't feel
guilty but I started looking on Reddit I
I follow a mountain biking thread and
the thing I'd never noticed until this
point was people occasionally will post
videos of themselves like doing jumps or
like doing all types of stuff for people
to analyze them and sometimes they'll
have their dogs chasing them and every
time the comments are just full of
people critic
the fact that you're doing this and I
started reading it and there's a lot of
compelling reasons like like more than I
can count on for everyone's sake your
dogs and for everyone's sake it's not
it's it's not it's not only an
inconsiderate idea but it's not a good
idea it's not a safe idea so you're
going to go basket only next
time I'm saying he's only going to be in
the basket no
you're saying you're not going to do it
at all no because I'm I can't do
anything worth doing with him in the
basket because then what if I fall again
what I couldn't live with myself if I
broke my collon and his so what you
gonna do with the basket uh it also is a
backpack so maybe if I hike with him and
Jade gets tired I'll put him in there
but it's kind of like a loss okay you
know what I was just I'm trying I'm
trying so hard and apparently my kids
knew it from the moment they saw it in
the Amazon cart that whatever plan you
have
Dad run it by us next time that's why I
have a different account just I I listen
I pay a little bit extra to have I need
that accountability to have my own
Amazon Prime because sometimes you want
to might you sometimes you might want to
buy something that you don't want the
kids to know about you know and I'm not
just talking about like a surprise for
them okay you know yeah yeah yeah all
right I mean what what do you do when
you want to do
that I like to go in
person no I I've bought I don't buy it
through Amazon yeah I don't yeah you
talking about
dildos
yeah that's cool man that's cool did you
brought that up I don't want my kids
know about dildos that I
buy I'm sitting in my son's dorm room
yeah right yeah exactly that can't
happen with my S my my
system oh gosh I'll cover two I'm
assuming I got more things than you yeah
I don't really have much I have some
things I I have not much elseed talk I
talked about this but I don't think I
said what exactly what it
was the Dr scholes go sockless
cushioning insoles the terry cloth
insoles just I can't recommend those
enough you you got now now the weather's
a little bit too cold I'm not I'm not
loafing it but I can't wait for the
weather to warm up again next year is it
terry cloth am I right about that uh
yeah but I don't think it has to be it's
like a wash rag in your loafer yeah yeah
yeah uh so I to hit that again um hit
that yeah hit that again so the other
thing that was a pretty significant
purchase for me
is you may remember on
GMM I don't know if it was oh it was
that maybe it was a mo where we had all
those um squishy toys right and I never
I never thought of myself as much of a
squishy
guy and
until we got that fre
piece of bread that squishy piece of
bread is it the same there was a lemon
with the
eyeball I don't know if it was the same
episode or not I know about the bread
though I think it was actually maybe it
was
earlier we were like let's try try these
different squishies and it was a slice
of bread a slice of bread like if you
just saw it on the ground You' be like
oh somebody left bread on the ground
until you picked it up and tried to eat
it and then you died from choking on
latex and
I brought it with us I first of all I
just found myself wanting to touch it
now I'm a guy who likes to touch rocks
okay what I like Smooth rocks so I do
have a little bit of a texture thing you
know there are people who like to touch
things you like to touch smooth rocks
and so I like a good smooth Rock I got
some smooth rocks in my office and a
little wooden bowl and sometimes I'll
just take it and I'll just hold it and
it and something about the texture is
comforting right I've never I didn't
know this about you uh I've never seen
you do that yeah you're too busy wetting
a bed um don't you uhuh that this is not
a
runner this is not the thing we keep
bringing back up again uh yeah I don't
do it often but I do have it
so but something about the squishy
nature of this thing I just felt myself
wanting to touch it wanting to stretch
it yeah and then we had a weekend with
friends right um and I don't know at
some point when we went to Big Sur we
went to Big Surf we had cabin and I let
everyone touch my bread and then in fact
maybe even encouraged everyone to touch
it yeah and there was a moment at
which music was playing Y and there was
a guitar solo right and I don't know who
started it but at some point we all
started taking turns playing the
bread as if it were making the sounds of
the guitar you talk about a good party
and it was so much fun it's better than
a pie eating contest yeah and so so
first of all I made a decision in that
moment that like I'm going to be a man
who likes squishy things and I'm going
to be a man who gives squishy bread to
people oh so I bought uh I don't know
how many of our friends listen to this
podcast so I might be spoiling the
surprise but the next time that group of
people gets together I've got a slice of
bread for every person you have a loaf's
worth of squishy bread and I have a loaf
so I have I have two you SE seen the
loaf I've got I've got a loaf that looks
like a nice baked piece of bread with
like a glossy like top like a but it
doesn't feel as good it's not as
stretchy I got that just to experiment
I've got that I like it but it you you
can't play that bread as well as you can
play my stretchy bread right when when
when BB King has really been in that
note you want to pull that bread yeah
pull it right because just to be totally
clear about the plane of the bread the
picture
air guitar but bread but squishy bread
squishy bread and it can be it can be
stretched so you can just sit there and
you can noodle on it mhm and and you're
and you're smooshing it with your
fingertips good as if you're like Eddie
Van Halen doing some finger tapping you
can really do whatever you want that
that is a common we discover that you
can do pretty much anything you want uh
and that can include stretching
stretching at the right time is really
it's a crowd pleaser it creates like a
neck I got a lot of laughs stretching at
the right time right and then the
contraction at the right time oh yeah
you got to come back you can't just stay
stretched and you can't stretch too far
because you don't want to break it if
you break the bread in the middle of a
solo it's almost as bad
as I feel like welcome to my world of
satis satisfaction
because here's why this bread that you
discovered is so great like you know
it's great when you touch it and you
squeeze it and you're you mouth starts
salivating not because you want to eat
bread but because you're So Satisfied
with the squishiness I didn't know that
was I don't know if that happened next
time you play the bread pay attention to
if you're slobbering well you like to
eat dog food though I bet you shut up I
bet you do I bet you do and
listen if you have an
urge you first you have an awareness
that there's something inside of this
squishy bread that is viscous yeah and
that makes it squishy but then you have
this
urge to push it to the breaking point to
to pierce it to to squirt
it and you're resisting that and so
there's
this I don't know what you would call it
there's this tension that you're it's
like just get it's like you're on the
edge of of just like of just like
compromising your I
I haven't broken it and I will say we
played that bread we played that bread
yeah we played that bread so hard that
that's the appeal the crust wore off of
it so now it's just all white it looks
like a
uncrustable no the ones I bought fully I
didn't even take them out of the package
because I'm handing them in the package
to each person I'm think I got a whole
thing a bread ceremony I'm trying to
figure out how I'm going to be Mr bread
I I don't know I I'm not I don't want to
overthink it we got I mean everybody
doesn't even live in this state so it's
like no but we were all planning on
getting back together you're waiting for
that and I got to wait until that to get
my bread you could go ahe and give me my
bread no no no no you're going to be
part of the bread ceremony I know I
don't want to wait for that it'll be
worth it delay gratification you're
going to love
it um it is it is truly great where do
people get this bread do you want to
tell them I got it on Amazon my there's
a number of them but the one I got is
toast sliced bread stress toy toast most
sliced bread stress toy I think this
might be clickable not a sponsor but we
have sold the hell out of this bread I'm
telling you um there's some that are
really cheap I got the one that was more
expensive because I was worried yeah I
mean I think I paid like $9 a piece for
like eight pieces of bread I paid 72
bucks for fake
bread hey this is the most money I've
ever spent on fake bread I I would you
should buy the probably the most money
I've ever spent on bread you should yeah
you should have bought the cheaper one
too cuz I want to know if if is it the
same it's probably the same I don't know
I feel like I got a good one cuz the
thing I don't want to do is I don't want
somebody playing the bread in for it to
pop MH right because I that'll ruin it
for everyone but getting as close as you
can to that yeah you want to think that
it's going to pop but you don't want
exactly it's not gonna pop it's not GNA
pop but you you want to make it pop a
little bit okay what else you got oh
what else I got cuz I mean I you know
I've got quite a list here
um uh not a sponsor though it it it I
think it was a mythical kitchen sponsor
and that a lot of people are sponsoring
this thing now including the whole Snoop
Dog thing oh solo stove I bought a solo
stove which they're saying is like it's
a fire pit and it's
smokeless I got one for the creative
house been enjoying that thing did you
use the the corporate card for
that yeah well yeah that's you should
but I mean it's just I mean I mean I
don't know I don't know it feels like I
feel like this is Maybe a technical
violation we bought a solo stove yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you haven't even
used it yeah I have I threw some logs on
it oh yeah that night yeah where was the
bread that night bread should have been
there um no no no the big loaf was
there oh oh and the little loaf was
there I played the bread that night the
little loaf don't you remember you
didn't play it memorably uh I did play
it but it was different cuz I'm
listen I the that wasn't the group that
wasn't the group for the bread ceremony
yeah yeah you're
right you're
right I did play it though it wasn't the
same I will admit it wasn't the same um
again they're not a sponsor but because
um and there there there's some other
competitors I just can't vouch for them
but I can vouch for the solo stuff uh
and they come in different sizes they're
pretty damn
pricey uh I think it's all hype I no cuz
you know Snoop did his whole I'm giving
up smoke right I mean how much much did
that man get paid for that because I
mean I was telling everybody that smoke
that that Snoop stopped smoking weed I'm
telling my in-laws over Thanksgiving I
did not fall for it I did not oh you
thought it was an ad the whole
time of course it's Snoop Dogg I mean
himmer Shack you know he's selling
something okay no no I I I'm questioning
your timeline I I think you found out
about it once everyone knew it was an ad
I thought he was going to launch an
edible
yeah but he said he was he was giv up
smoke he said
smoke yeah so you so well I'm not saying
I didn't think he was going to be doing
Edibles I'm just saying I thought that
he was saying that he was legitimately
we were never going to see well that's
what he wanted think joint but that's
what I didn't think do you feel
cheated uh it did feel a little cheap
yeah when he was selling a solo stove
yeah yeah yeah I mean how much did he
get paid for that how much did he get
paid not enough
probably well not enough with the amount
you pay for these things they could
probably afford to turn around and pay
him so what is it how 400 bucks I can't
remember uh I did get the biggest one
and then the accessories are exorbitant
so you got to watch yourself but I will
say there's just something magical about
like burning wood in a social setting
and but you don't want to have that
smoke chasing you around where you're
like oh I got to move my chair got to
move my chair and it smokes at first
first once you get a couple of logs
going then it stops it does stop smoking
and does it stop smoking because of the
air flow yes so also goes through more
wood faster it it eats through some wood
yeah but there is no smoke it's just an
it's an amazing fire it's so hot there's
no smoke Jenna you've seen it yeah yeah
my my aunt and uncle have one as well at
their house it's awesome but I will say
it does smoke when the log that you put
in there has plastic wrapped around it
yeah yeah you kind that's what you did
it was dark it was really dark and we
had we you you been playing quite a bit
of toast already you got all you got all
the wood and it was all wrapped up and
I'm out there cutting it and then I'm
like I can't see anything but I don't
think there's any plastic on
this and me and water standing next to
the fire and I'm like that that thing
for something that's not supposed to
smoke that is some black smoke that is
some toxic smoke coming out of that
thing yeah it was it'll it will smoke if
you put plastic in
it that's mine what else you got
um I was at the
dentist the earlier in the year and I
already told you about my issue with
trying to they're making me come back
every four months because of how it's
like how quickly the buildup comes back
yeah and they're like is something to do
with like this your saliva or whatever
and they're and they're like you got to
be flossing you got to be so I'm doing
everything they blamed your spit uh yeah
it's something about the so it's it's
not sometimes it can have nothing you
got sugary spit Can it have anything to
do with sugar it has to do with the pH
or something okay and so I'm like well
it's never been a problem before but you
know you get older things change so I uh
she's like what floss do you use I'm
like uh you know the one that you get at
the store I don't think about it or
whatever and she's like oh you don't
need to use like a
waxed you don't need to use a waxed
floss that's not doing anything that
might be dislodging some food but
there's no abrasive nature to it oh so
she's like you need to
get some floss that actually hurts
that's dry and so I found this floss
that's made from
coconut cocoa floss biodegradable or
something or um Coco I mean it's vegan
and cruel free uh anyway cocoa
floss probably the most expensive floss
that I've ever bought uh not as much
it's not as expensive as fake bread is
it in a big roll or because it's from a
coconut it's shorter strands it looks
the same I got three I got it comes in a
pack of three that I don't know it's
probably like $20 for three you'll never
go through it all you'll stop for I've
already been through it and I bought
more I floss every single night you're
still doing that without exception it is
I like I don't care how tired I am I
don't care what I've been doing I'm like
you floss and then you brush your teeth
with the electric toothbrush and you
wash your face no matter
what you better do it yeah that's how
you talk to yourself yeah yeah and if
you do that you can play the bread you
you can you can't play that bread until
you floss brush and wash your face so uh
I've been doing it and listen I go to
the dentist on Friday and so I you're
hoping and I you know I could because
we've been so busy I had to postpone my
dentist appointment twice so it's been
like seven
months but boy if they give me a bad
report I'm going to be so disappointed
but I've been using this stuff so I'll
let you know if it was worth it but it
feels good and you feel like you're
getting stuff you feel like you're
rubbing the side of your tooth you're
becoming obsessive man in your in your
age every single time I go to the
dentist they tell me I got a problem
your I never had a problem your problem
is your health anxiety and you know
that the no when the doctor tells you
that you have a problem that's not
anxiety when you tell yourself that you
have a problem and WebMD is where you go
that's fling every day you're supposed
to floss every day no but nobody no they
say that so that you'll do it
occasionally okay when you when all your
teeth fall out of your head I'm the one
who chew who's chewed 30 times his
entire life because I yeah you're like
an elephant and your tee your m going to
out I I I'm just saying I'm trying to
spare you like I spent my whole life
mtic ridiculously trying to be perfect
and now you're
trying what what is that it was just a
good setup for a joke but I won't do it
I won't make the joke no make it let's I
can take it no I've spent my entire life
trying to be perfect yeah trying that's
it yeah right something okay you know
wasn't
that that wasn't even good anyway you're
you should have this floss because even
if you don't
what kind of floss are you using I don't
equate I don't floss at all if I eat
corn or ribs I'll break out some string
yeah otherwise how are you getting in
between your teeth what are you doing I
use my tongue your tongue cannot remove
plaque don't you tell me what my tongue
between your tongue between your teeth
you ever heard of a silver tongue
devil uh yeah
well if don't you think he could remove
plaque I don't know what you're trying
to do I don't know what you're trying to
say at this point honestly no I I after
a meal I'll I'll I'll I'll use my tongue
to explore my teeth and make sure
there's nothing in there but here but
this is the thing and I know that you're
talking about scraping pla my flossing
because I actually feel very differently
about this my flossing is unrelated is
actually a good like for me it's good my
health anxiety health anxiety is when
you think about something that isn't
happening and you worry about something
that might happen Okay that's true and
so I have that problem but this is not
that problem this is actually good
because it's real just don't well and
I'm being told by my doctor to do it my
dentist just don't brush your teeth too
hard because they also told me that yeah
I don't do that I don't brush them too
hard I might brush them too often well
tce a day all right I'll let you off to
hook I
bought
um uh what am I going to tell you that I
um this is actually Christy's purchase
but I I did want to talk about it I
don't think I've told this story okay
again maybe a violation of the rule but
okay I just don't buy I don't buy
interesting things but I thought this is
interesting she bought a handheld carbon
monoxide detector and I don't think I
told the story on the podcast uh forgive
me if I have but like you know um back
early this year we went to we went to
Cabo and we went with with a couple of
friends and we like stayed in this place
and it was like these this nice uh
Resort where you had like different uh
Cabana type things and then there's a
fire pit and we're like hanging out by
the fire pit and then a couple of weeks
later chrisy sends me this article and
she's
like this
couple uh was at the resort and she
started to figure out that she thought
they were in like the same room that our
friends were in or in one just like the
one our friends were in and you can you
can see where this is going they started
to feel sick mhm and then they went to
the Urgent Care and then they checked
them out they since they started to feel
better they didn't discover anything
they went back to the resort went back
to bed and woke up the next morning dead
from carbon monoxide poisoning oh Jenna
you think that's funny sry the Wake
waking up in the morning dead is is
funny to me they probably didn't they
probably didn't wake up and way to say
it feels like we had a brush with carbon
monoxide poisoning ourselves because the
gas line was messed up Y at the fire pit
that we were at and then we had to call
the guy out there to like get the fire
pick going and apparently some some of
it and one of these places was leaking
into a bedroom and they didn't have
carbon monoxide detectors
installed that's that feels like a
problem I think that that's a problem it
should be like and I'm not going to say
well it's Mexico because I don't think
that's true
either but it probably is the law and
I'm in America for people to have carbon
well let me tell you this every other
place that we've gone including our own
bedroom you best believe that Chris has
been firing up that carbon monoxide
detector how often does she do it oh
she's every night she's got she's got a
holster for
it she sleeps with it
um and what does it do she might have a
little bit of what you got you know what
I'm saying she might have a little bit
more than I got she might have a little
bit more than what you got based on my
conversations with her
right yeah so uh she never detected any
carbon monoxide right it'll probably
stay that way so maybe the detector is
not working what I tell her you need a
detector for the detector is what I told
her well you need to go into an
environment that you know is is
compromised or send someone maybe um she
doing at your house I've seen it out
yeah and what what how does it work we
do have carbon monoxide detectors
they're in our fire detector you just
hold it up into the air yeah yeah yeah
it's like a handheld and it gives you
ating you're good to go keep breathing
it's just think about it if you can if
you if there's a circular one you can
mount to your ceiling it if it doesn't
off if it doesn't go off it's hand
helmet
yeah she hold it up to your
face why why do you ask that because I'm
a silver tongue devil because a lot of
hot air comes
out hold it up to your face probably
detect actually it would detect if it
doesn't detect is it carbon dioxide that
comes out of your mouth not carbon
monoxide yeah that's a different you
might have some monoxide I don't
know I mean I I I get I mean I don't
know you starting to wet to bed as an
adult I don't know what's going on you
might have monoxide com
man okay um I bought something
that I feel like I ended up making you
buy that you probably forgotten about
which might be the most significant
purchase you've made all
year I think it may have been it
probably wasn't as much as that solo
stove but we paid for that together you
know what I'm talking about what what
genre are we in it was a situation can
you buy it at Walmart in no it was a
situation in which I did the thing that
I do which is when I get into something
I get equipped properly talking about a
GPS no for the solo trip I bought a a a
satellite tracker I had already I
already had that satellite phone I
bought one because you had one yeah yeah
and then you know what I was looking out
for you yeah no I bought something and
you were there when I bought it and you
were like okay I guess I'll buy it too
you bought the same exact one that I
bought and I'm telling you it had to
be it had to be one of your biggest
purchases of the
year uh you're talking about solar
panels
no no we were in a store together buying
things to get ready for something buying
things to get ready for something
something that I started doing because
you started doing it but then the way I
did it was the way that I do it
skiing and snowboarding no but close an
activity uh I'm glad that you know this
what kind of activity this represents
growth for you because you didn't
register that you spent like 350 bucks
on a
bag a
bag oh a scuba bag yeah the dve bag oh
yes I was looking at that the other I
was like damn I bought that bag and and
I could see the pain in your eyes when
you bought it too
right because we went to we went we were
going to go on the the scuba trip uh the
one where we saw the orcas and all that
and like we were at our you know we were
at Hollywood divers shout out to
Hollywood divers that's our dive shop I
had to get a warmer suit for myself and
uh which was a Splurge we got all this
like you know you got your mask and your
fins and your wet suit and you've got
the things that you don't want to have
to keep renting every time but then what
are you going to do with it put it in a
trash bag no you're going to put it in a
dive bag that has wheels
yeah so that me and shepher can put all
our in one bag and I'm just looking
at the bags I'm like well that one looks
like the best one that's what I'm going
to get and then you look at me and I'm
like I don't think I need a bag yeah and
then you bought it and I and you but
like you've used it more than me because
you went diving again I haven't been
diving since that point since that you
went you you you went diving with
Lincoln you used it yeah it's a good bag
it's a great bag it's a great bag I
almost used it twice but the conditions
weren't oh yeah you were to go back and
see the seals give birth uh the
conditions they the guy called it off
the day before yeah I bought a bag and
you know what I since then this has been
the year of me buying bags you know I
talked about my fanny bag yeah my my
sling bag I I am still fully committed
to going with that thing everywhere M
and I do it and then I bought a uh I
bought a weekend pack to go along with
it that it goes in the top of it and I
can like and then I bought Christy one
and I'm like oh we're a weekend pack
we're gonna go to we're going to go to
New Zealand and we're going to be like
outdoor trekking people and we're going
to have like these
bags I went on this the Coto poxy or
Coto pxi I don't know how you say it
website and I just got enamored with
this stuff you you you'll fall for bags
which is why I thought I was doing you a
favor when I got a really nice bag and
so and then I bought I got a new laptop
bag from them yep did you notice that
today was the first day I brought it in
did you notice it yeah yeah I mean there
hard to keep up with how many bags you
got 100% recycled materials to make
these bags and uh I just like their
ethos I got to get a good bag for the
all the bread I'm going to give out you
know what else I bought I bought a
toiletry bag I got a new backpack a new
toiletry bag I got Christy a backpack I
got me a weekend backpack does your
toiletry bag can you hook it and then it
unravels no oh I figured you would have
done that
no
and for Christmas I bought myself a
snowboard that was my big one and then
and
Boots yeah oh that cost more than a bag
because Lincoln is like he wants to get
in snowboarding I'm like you know what
I'm going to get back into snowboarding
I can do it l Michael can do it so that
was that was my big Christmas present to
myself and then I'm like and you know
what I need
need a bag I need a bag for my St you
got to buy a bag so here I am thanks to
you yeah I think yeah I didn't trace it
back I opened your year to bags you're
my You're My Bag Boy yep you you've
opened open my world to bag and I it's
like I'll open up a box and there'll be
I'm like a like my mother-in-law is
obsessed with purses yep and now I get
it I totally get it oh I wonder how when
I open up this bag I wonder how many
zippers how many other pockets are going
to be inside of it how am I going to be
able to organize everything and have
everything it's like it's and it feels
good it feels almost as good as playing
bread but not as good but not as playing
bread mhm and you know what I once you
give me that bread I probably need a bag
to carry it in maybe I'll give everybody
a little little Crown Royal bag for
their bread I'm going to I'm going to
keep my bread in my fanny pack I'm going
to keep it with me at all times well I I
mean I have been thinking not just about
giving bread to that group but I've been
thinking about you know as we as I've
been talking about having these events
that I still they're still very like
nebulous in my mind but I have been
thinking that one of the things that I
would like to do if the event was not
too big is to always have maybe bread
for everybody but a different kind of
bread like everybody gets like a biscuit
like maybe the sliced bread is just for
that group but then oh if you go to
party at Red's house he'll give you
he'll give you some squishy biscuits
squishy biscuit just something just
something like that just so they have
something to remember you know I think
usually shall we break bread together
and then they all try to break it and
they can't cuz it's squishy almost break
bread it's a prank almost break bread
together um you see I think this might
play into like your Jesus
complex Jesus complex you can't tell
somebody that they have a Jesus complex
just because I get accused of looking
like the Mormon Jesus on a regular basis
doesn't mean I have a Jesus complex
isn't that what it is uh when you when
you're mistaken the Loaves and the
fishes when you're mistaken for maybe
trying to do like a like maybe you're
the backup guy on the chosen series or
something like that right yeah yeah yeah
Jesus complex yeah but that's I mean
that's I don't know if that's a complex
I think that's just um
opportunistic um but I maybe I do you
get some squishy fish too as well you're
multiplying the bread maybe if I get
some squishy fish or maybe maybe I the
fishes maybe I just Swedish Fish and
they're squishy but you can eat them
Loaves and Fishes there you go that's
your party um I purchased as you know I
have somewhat of a smart
home and um where I like to say things
to my home and then my home does things
right yeah not everything is smart but
as many lights as possible are those
Lutron lights yeah yeah yeah right you
you told us about this last year well or
two years ago yeah but I'm telling you
about the update first of all have you
ever have you Lutron yet no you don't
have any Lutron I I've we moded right
but you but you can like when you go to
bed you don't have to worry that you've
left lights on no okay that's just
making
sure well a few lights
but keep going Jesse when she redid the
outside area in our
home she wanted a fountain like a you
know this little fountain that trinkles
some water right yeah I know what a
fountain is and uh as you know as you
have experienced one of my favorite
things to do at my house is to touch
rocks watch um is to the Fountain no is
to watch television outside okay yes and
um I had you over for my birthday party
and we did that and thank you now
when I
say Fountain hey Google outdoor movie
The Fountain turns off the fountain
turns off that Fountain is so damn loud
the lights change but the fountain goes
off because Lutron makes a uh a
weatherproof outdoor smart plug that's
just an onoff switch so you can just PL
anything into it yeah you're like your
lights outside like it's not just for
fountains but like your voice controls
water you have an Aquaman complex no
that's still kind of a Jesus complex
well it's a Jason Mamoa complex well no
cuz Jes and we know you have that Jesus
could make he could walk on water and he
can turn the water to wine I still think
we're squarely in Jesus
territory what can Aquaman M Fountain
stop I have not watched those movies I
think he just has a a
trident not a
sponsor cuz a gum cuz of
gum I don't want to talk talk about
anything else at off really I feel like
it's only been met with
ridicule every time I say something you
say that I'm
Jesus well yeah I ridicule you you
ridicule my
purchases and that hurts what did you
what was the last thing you said I
didn't ridicule it what was it uh well
you said that it was it didn't count you
said none of my things count I no I say
that you violated some what I just
unofficial rules of the list which is
something that you bought for yourself
okay not something you bought for us or
something your wife bought but if that's
the way that you need to fill out your
list then maybe we'll just amend the
rules I'm not you know I'm not a
stickler for rules you know that my last
thing
uar that is a yuo y a
r u r two pack sunglasses holder another
bag really it's well it's a clip it's a
kind of bag it's a you put it you're
driving and you got a bunch of
glasses and you feel like wearing a
certain type of glass glasses and so on
my visor in my car I have bought I
actually bought multiple sets of these I
have three
clips and three different types of
glasses in my car and then I was like
you know what I'm going do Christy a
favor and I got two in Christy's car one
of them's for my glasses and yeah cuz
it's like I don't like I have to switch
my prescription of my sunglasses okay so
that's two clips and then maybe just so
you're saying that and then I have other
tight I have sunglasses that can also
read with but that make me sick when I
drive with and those were up there but
then those were
replaced they're all up there
convenient but in just in your car what
do you do when you drive your wife's car
I have them in there too and I have
different sunglasses in there you got
sunglasses just for your wife's car yeah
prescription sunglasses it's a safety
thing that's a different set
yeah okay what about when you drive some
you steal a car well now I have my fanny
pack which I care with with me at all
times you can't be thwarted at this
point nope um that's the last thing
you're G to talk about done I've got to
speed through a few I am so done with
this one of my most significant
purchases of this year is those hocus I
got those comfortable shoes that were
prominently featured in our we took a
nap video they they they
floated yeah you know um I got to say
most comfortable pair of shoes that I've
ever had the Bondi eights if you're in
the if you're in the market for to walk
on clouds I'm just going to tell you you
got to get some um I got one of those
little uh midi controllers oh yeah
that's cool the aai I guess it is AK
AI uh just really
small put in your laptop bag it just
looks like a miniature keyboard yeah but
you know we've been making a lot more
music
for the r Link channel and uh and also
like we did the the the GMM intro this
year and that was all done on that
little keyboard right like not having to
like we've been doing a lot more of our
own music making and producing versus
farming we still Farm stuff out and
still get people to help us with things
but like I don't know there's a whole
little world opened up on that thing you
keep it in your laptop bag uh I do it's
in my car right now it's just on the
back of my car but you could travel with
it you can travel with it yeah I highly
recommend that um I
uh I got because you know we're going
back to North Carolina more often and I
really like flying with a guitar is like
a you don't want to do that you know
there's so many horror stories about
that I was like I got to get me like a a
solid a acoustic guitar that I that I to
have in North Carolina it' be my North
Carolina guitar oh right you know it's
like my home guitar and I'm going to go
to Harry's guitars remember Harry's
guitars in Raleigh yeah which moved it
moved it's a different location it's not
in downtown Raleigh anymore I don't care
but it's just I mean it was a little
disappointing but it moov but it's
bigger okay I haven't told you about
this guitar I didn't know you bought a
guitar I mean you have why didn't you
just take one you didn't want to fly
with one that you have here you got four
here R uh well half of them my kids play
them my kids break them I've got like my
kids have broken so many of my guitars
okay and
um I got a
guild You' seen the guild You' seen
those Guild Guitars yeah yeah like a
guild well I just was actic guitar it's
just a it's just like they like 140 it's
like you know like the the base the the
the the the lowest level solid top you
mean
Gildan no the t-shirts uh it should it
it plays so good I've never played I
never picked up a guild guitar butter
it's just so it just I love it it just
it's great and what's the bread factor
is it like uh it's got probably eight
out of 10 on bread okay it's not it's
not as good as the bread um wow I got a
I bought a robe this
year I you know I I bought a robe yeah
we get robes for free some for some
reason M yet you still had to buy one
well we get like YouTube robes that say
like Good Mythical Morning on them and
things like that like I don't want to be
that guy you know it's like what's your
YouTube channel look at my robe you know
I've got a Wing Stop robe again I Wing
Stop sent us a robe in fact the other
night Jesse comes out with a robe and
she says why do we have a Wing Stop robe
and I'm like baby it's it's you married
the right guy
lifestyle you married a man that get
sent Wing Stop robes it is a nice
lifestyle when you can walk around robes
I mean but there's a company shout out
to highway robbery get
it uh I fell victim to their Instagram
ads and uh what's so good about their
robes they're just cool looking they're
just cool looking paisy and it's and
it's uh it's striped and it's light it's
a light robe summer robe it's a summer
robe I try to stretch it into the winter
it's California you can do that I just
feel like you know I'm past my mid- 40s
really
46 I'm heading to late 40s I just feel
like it's time it's time for cool
ropes um last two things oh gosh thank
goodness um I and I'll
talk I mean this may be this may be
bleeding over into my top moments you
know what I'm going to save it for my
top moments because I bought something
that then translated into a top moment
that I'll talk about next week yeah save
that but the last thing is and maybe
this this might
encapsulate this year for us as a
um as a
species I bought I started
paying for chat GPT mhm it's like uh
monthly or annual type thing how what's
that run
you maybe it was 20 bucks a month oh
really I can't remember what it was um
but but I haven't done that I uh and
honestly I'm thinking about not like I
don't know I use it on and
off and I haven't like used it I used it
more when I first started to do it and
it was more in the I don't know if he
talked about this on the on the podcast
but like I've used it in exercises where
I wanted to ask it a question that I
would ask Google or ask it to summarize
something or or if I'm trying to
generate a list of things like what um
oh I'll tell you I'll tell you where I
used it and this is an example of it not
doing a good
job so the song The Egg song that's in
the latest WR link video
Yeah and of course the the premise of
the song is that this whole idea that
over easy is harder to do than over hard
right sends your you not your character
you into an existential crisis right and
then where other
truths well and you say would sound
backwards well and you say next thing
you know you'll tell me that Iceland is
green and Greenland is covered in ice MH
and I'm like uh yeah it's
true well that was what I thought of
right but when I I went on chat GPT and
I was
like give me an example of something
that the name for it is actually
describes I don't know how I described
it but I was like overh hard is harder
is easier to make than over easy and I
was like such as Greenland is covered in
ice and Iceland is green because
everybody knows that and then people are
like well driveway Parkway whatever
there's a few examples right and so the
great thing about chat GPT is it can
generate the sensibly it can generate
all
known examples of that but it didn't
give me anything better than what I had
already come up with which is the
Greenland thing and I was like I didn't
did it give you the driveway Parkway
yeah but I didn't I didn't want to do
anything that people already knew about
right I was kind of disappointed in that
line I I was happy with it when I first
heard the Greenland and Iceland because
I was like cuz it was a song about eggs
I wanted to be more unexpected that was
unexpected but but apparently it doesn't
exist or at least chat GPT so that's how
I've been using it this year is when I'm
like am I going to like find a website
that has like idioms listed yeah when
you know the criteria for something and
you know there's probably an answer
that's and I'm sure I'm not I'm
definitely not taking full advantage of
it you know and I'm not like I'm not
using it it's not writing things like oh
write a script or tell me a joke it's
more like this is something that I could
go through a long process of getting
somebody to do or searching U but anyway
I just I thought that that
was we I assume we'll look back
on this year is oh yeah you remember
2023 is the year when like everybody
kind of started understanding what that
first AI tool was that we what was it
called chat GPT yeah yeah what is it now
it's whatever it's going to be it's our
Consciousness yeah right it's our
president right exactly it's the
government uh all right it's it's my
wreck baby wck baby one two three today
I I I'm going to I'm just going to pick
pick something we talked about like what
if I can only pick one thing what's the
what's the thing that could have the
most impact in people's lives that we've
discussed
today um a bag probably maybe a bag
probably uh I I guess I got to go with
the handheld carbon monoxide detector
you know what it could save a life when
in doubt or two uh get one and take it
with you whenever you're staying
somewhere and use it I just I just
conceivably saved a life
good for you man yeah put it in your bag
with your fake
bread I was just trying to add something
yeah or just get fake bread pretty good
thanks for joining us we're going to be
talking about the top moments of the
year next week in the meantime leave us
a message I had a good I had a good time
today good good work likewise yeah it
going one hey guys I just got my Spotify
wrapped and turns out I'm in the top one
% of your listeners and you guys are
obviously my top podcast so I just
wanted to thank youall for making my
walks to class and you know time doing
the dishes way better so yeah to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical
best
[Music]